28 años del atentado a la asociación
mutual israelita argentina amia el acto
terrorista más mortífero de la historia
del país que causó la muerte a 85
personas y dejó unas 100 heridas a las
953 del 18 de junio de 1994 un camión
cargado de explosivos estalló frente al
edificio y este lunes cientos de
personas se reunieron para conmemorar a
las víctimas
a 28 años de tu ausencia cristiana
y me queda de voz
me queda de voz la historia la que te
apasionadas estudiadas y nuestra
historia
la que amiga y disfrute la amia aún pide
justicia tras años de impunidad cómo
explicar que en 28 años no se ha podido
atrapar siquiera uno de los múltiples
responsables de semejante atrocidad que
los canallas miserables y asesinos de 85
personas siguen disfrutando de su vida
diaria paseando por el mundo con total
libertad como se explica tanta impunidad
en febrero de 2019 un tribunal argentino
absolvió al ex presidente carlos menem
que gobernó el país entre 1989 y 1999
acusado de conspirar para desviar las
investigaciones sobre el atentado el ex
mandatario siempre negó una mala
actuación en 2015 horas antes de
comparecer ante el legislativo apareció
muerto el fiscal alberto nisman conocido
por intentar exponer acusaciones contra
la entonces presidenta cristina
fernández por supuestamente encubrir la
participación de irán en el atentado
tribunales argentinos se atribuyen los
hechos a hezbollah pero no se ha juzgado
a nadie en relación con esta teoría el
viernes pasado el presidente argentino
alberto fernández recibió a las
autoridades de la amia y ratificó su
compromiso por el esclarecimiento de los
hechos